[音楽]
ブードゥー君
それではまず初めにですね頭の体操からいきたいとおもいます
何かいいなぁと思うかもしれませんけどもこちらポテトサラダ
うん
これはですね実は私のビジネスのお仲間で福島県はいわき市でね
回転寿司をやられているで村さんという方が考えたあいやなんですけどもまぁ回転寿司
ですからまあいろんなサイドメニューがあるわけですよね
その中で悩み事がありましたそれが何かと言ったらポテトサラダ
o 0辺のですよねえーまぁ卵を使っ
ているマヨネーズ使っているだからまあ作ったその日か翌日くらいには売り切れて
ほしいんですけども
こうメニュー表にねポーンとのおいているだけではお客さんの食者動けへんとさあそこ
で
でもらさんどういう風にしたかというとこのポテトサードの前に猫のポテトサード前に
枕詞をつけて売り上げた
を上げることができたさあここで皆さんがで村さんの立場だったらどんな枕詞をつけて
売り上げ上げようとしますかという頭の体操ですちょっと頭の中で23ここを思い描け
てみてください
いろんなネエ言葉が出てきたじゃないかなと思うんですが実はこれねこんな風にして
売り上げ上げたんですね
お店の看板娘澪ちゃんが作ったポテトサラダ250円と面白いですよねユウユすごく
ユニークでまぁ普通のポテトサラダから何かねこう魅力的な豊かなものねなんか伝わっ
たかそういう風になっていくと思うんですよね
でまぁおかげさまでねこんな感じでね企業さんの商品とかサービスとかそれをどういう
ふうに伝えれば猫より広く伝わるかってそういう伝え方高知
最近ではね学校の先生とかあるいはそのプレゼンテーションの海の労力をあげたいとか
そういった人たちにも指導させていただきてがずいぶんと増えまして
今からですね8年前ですが2010年ね大阪は天満天神繁昌亭というところで楽をか
入門講座てのがありました
そこでネバーぷろなぁはねはぁの噺家さんにお月謝を払ってでも抵抗つけていただくと
いう
まぁそこに入門いたしましたしゃべるのスキルを伸ばしたいあるいはねこうここぞと
いう時に笑いをターンと取れるようなそんな人間
になりたいと思いまして入門しまして半年が経ちましてちょうど修了式ですは当時で
上方落語協会会長でいらっしゃいました桂三枝
で6台分4章でございますけれどもその師匠からお名前をいただいて8県や県市という
名前でね
アマチュアですけども素人ですけどもボランティアで
地元尼崎を中心にも楽をさせてもらってるんですね
でまぁ初めの2年ぐらいはねえまあ身内とか知り合い相手に落語しすることが多かった
んで
まぁこんな私の名やたくその話でも皆にこやかに聞いてくれてたんですが
思い出しますね2012年2月25日です今でも思い出しますね
まあ
たく縁もゆかりもないところからねあのらくをの依頼を受けたんですよ私で気合入って
ましたねもうコードして喜んだ
癒し車頃何が何でもねもう笑わせたのやないかーいうて当日の衣装がこんな感じでね
煽り文付きでドーンといったわけですよ a で楽をやるね場所をネタカイザーと書い
て講座と言うんですけどねその口座にバーッと言って粘っを座ってね
よっしゃはローしたので一気をよと喋り始めたつ
そうすると最初のうちはねおじいちゃんおばあちゃんねーさん40人がイヤー兄ちゃん
よ起きていく
だなあああいう感じにこやかにこっちを見てくれてたんですけどもこれが3分たち5分
たちになってきたらどうなってきたかというと
a だんだんみんなそうそうそうそうし始めた
中にはね時計を見るような人も出てきたりして
でこれ話の音半ばの10本ぐらいなってくると半分ぐらいの人がう
ネオ工芸始めた
はが話の終わりの18分になるとなんと私を呼んだ主催者ですら
みんな夢の中に入ってしまったよ
これはね私屈辱的でしたねあの話か殺すとに刃物は要らぬ悪ビーズ3つ即死するてな
こと言いますけどね
私速習ところはございませんよねもう何回輪廻転生のあかんがいうぐらい
それぐらいのコツ所機次な事が起きたその時思いましたねぇ
どうやったらあの時おじいちゃんおばあちゃん起こすこと
できたらどうやったら終わらすことができたんやろいろいろ考えていろんな人に意見を
聞いていろんな本読んだ
a その時に私学生地で演劇をやってたんで
つかこうへいさんというね劇作家の方が書かれた文章がちょっと頭にパーンとう
よみがえってきたんです
その時塚さんこんな風に言ってるんですね例えば
ね男と女の海での別れのシーンがあるとところがね男と女は彼を支えるようなそんな
烏山も弓矢てあるわけじゃないとどこに行ったっていう日本海たでアースが入ったんが
なんか見たたあるわけがないと
でもこれがお芝居で演劇だったらね
役者がめっちゃ上手でポケット舌込みながらトーク見て
さあも読みですね
ってこういうふうにつぶやけばね波の大人がなくてもじゃあ分寒い海になる
南極以上の2人の悲しい海が出来上がる
これが観客のね想像力を駆り立てて豊穣な世界につながるんだということを書いてあっ
たわけです
なるほどそういうことかと a 私がおじいちゃんおばあちゃんを起こすことができ
なかったのは
を開いての想像力へ働きかけることはて来んかったから
なるほどなあとそういうふうに思ったんですが
さあここでつかさんのいうイメージの北条集まり相手を創造力を駆り立てる
イメージの豊穣祭いったいどこから黒んか
ということをちょっと考え始めたわけですそんな時に一番有名な俳句の口があるんです
けどもこれに出会ったわけですね
柿食えば鐘が鳴るなり法隆寺
正岡子規がね選んだ空の中でも一番有名な空だと言われてますけども
これねいつも私を聞くんですよ皆さんにね日本全国で聞くんですけどもさー
この正岡子規の句1日24時間の中で何時ぐらいに選んだ空ですかと
1日24時間何時くらいですかと聞きますそうすると80%から90%の人は夕方です
かという風に答えるんですねまぁ中にはねアーマー夜中ですかとかを3時ですかた
まあまあああけあったんですかっていうふうに言われる方もたまにはいらっしゃいます
たまにはいるけども
8割から9割の人は5時か6時ぐらいの夕方ですかというふうに言われるんですよ
そういうとき私聞くんですねあーなるほど夕方ですかああ干したらこれ寝床に夕方て
書いてますかって聞くんどぅ
書いてないんですよ書いてないにもかかわらず今私はな皆さんの頭の中にはもうね夕日
が落ちていって法隆寺がシルエット映っててそこにカラスが飛んでてガーンとなって
いるようななんかそういうノスタルジックなイメージを頭の中に描いたんじゃないです
か
100%全然伝えていないのに何故そんな豊穣な
いうイメージを開いてくるのかそう私が考えた穴はこちらなんですね
実は100%伝えるんじゃなくてこの20%の余白を残してあげること
これが実は豊かさを生み出す源泉やないかなとそんな風に思うだしたんですね
じゃあぐ
第的にこれどういうふうなことになってるかちょっとお話をしたいと思いますが今から
ねお見せするのは崇徳院というね
落語のネタの一節なんです主人公のは花壇さんが町の中で偶然出会った女性
それに一目惚れしたんですねその時にこの女性を形容する宇野がこんな風な言い方なん
です
お歳の頃なら中
18を灯し後に連れたそれはそれは美しい水持たれるような綺麗なお方よりは鬱やかな
人があるもんやなあと見とれてたとこれは崇徳院と1節なんですけどもあるいは断水を
説明する時にこんな感じですね
ダンさんはゼロスラットだかいろんな桜井目のパッチリとした苦味の端たいい男で
とこれは悋気の独楽というネタの一説です
今男女の用紙の話をしましたた
といえば女性を形容するときにね北川景子さんみたいなシュッとして美人なんやで
あるいは八千草薫さんみたいなものゴッチ上品でな
べっぴんさんやったやだというふうに言われても
まあええ北川景子さん八千草薫さん知ってる人からすればああっなるほどそんな美人で
物品の端回やって
になりますけれどもこれ知らない人かすると a
どんどんだけ美人でべっぴんのがようわからんババーンまから塗りと言って想像力が
そこでストップしてしまうわけですよねあああるいは男性を形容する時でもね
まるまるさん見てもの乙イケメンでかっこよくてハンサムやねと言われてもそれ
聞いた本人がまるまるさんも好気合だったらいい
判断22点の最悪みたいなしてことになってしまうわけです
だから物事をぼかして伝えるということが実は重要なスキルになってくるんですがこれ
が日常生活でも使えるわけなんですね
例えばこういう例えば雨が降ってるとしましょうね天気予報を見てた
明日ママ1時間に100ミリの雨が降るでしょう
と言う
割れてはぁなるほどそんなすごい雨がフロン化とイメージできるのはこれ気象予報士
ぐらいしかないわけですよね
我々からすると大いまいちをわからんなあとまあ確かにこの100名という数字は
で事実を伝えている正確無比なのかもしれませんけども
でもそこにね雨のたたずまいとかあるいは汁の匂いとか
そういうものは一切感じることができないわけなんですよね
だからこれをどういうふうに言い換えるかというと例えば
で滝のように55と雨が降り出したでとかあるいは車軸を流しを舐めがぺああっと降っ
てきたと
そんな風に言われる方が我々のイマジネーション創造旅行駆り立てるわけです
例えば心臓の音でもそうですよね心臓が今ドキドキしてねって言われるのと
新聞のバック付録4年と言われるのとどっちが緊張感ありますか
それはバクバクのほうじゃないですかねえあるいはお歌の世界でも同じことです
うさぎおいしかの山湖ぶな釣りしかのかは有名な故郷ねひとつの部分ですけども
ああこれね金山可能変わってねぼかしてくれてるからわれわれはこのスタのジックな
イメージをすることができる
例えばね具体的な山川入れたらどうなるかって
例えばうさぎ美味しい甲山とかね
小鮒都留市神崎がわーとか言われてもなぁが僕ら幸兵衛とから京阪神の人間やからなん
とラバーの
なるほどなあとわかりますけどこれよその人からするとどう
所や墓はやねんっていう風になってしまうわけですよね
だからやっぱ赤の山彼の母でぼかすことによって我々が幼い時に見た幻風景山母がそこ
にフラッシュバックしてイメージが登場になっていくと
てね
今から一つね物事100%伝えたとしても伝わらないレート今からお見せしますはどう
いったことが出てこういう文書があるとしますね
っぽ機は2000年以上ないね標高843m の山の麓
まあ70歳の国旗を超えたであろうそうそうか言いました
ある5月の家
13時頃のどかな田園風景の中
たはの幅300メートルの代わりしでおばあさんが一人選択をしていると
をはるか川上580メートルほど前のところからもう直径60センチの大きな桃が
あああ時速5km 弱のスピードで流れてきたぁー
というのをたった一言で表すと
ドンブラコになろう
すごいですよね今私はレネ読み上げた255条あるんですよ
その250文字がたったの5文字表現できるんです
皆さんよく考えてみてください今までの人生の中でね母で選択しててひょっとみたら
向こうからでもが流れてきてそれをタッチしていいに持って帰った経験がある人
いないんです世界中どこを探してもいないんですよでも我々は
で定点したことがないのに過去のとんぼラップを聞いただけであれだけのことを無意識
的意識かかわらずらーーーっとも描くんですよ
だからねまあもう太郎は世界的な名作って言われてるけども
海外からも評価が高いそしてねこのドンブラコイオン語義たようなんですけども
海外の人からするとね日本語すごいよハンパねーよってなるんですよ
ああそれだけ評価が高いんですじゃあそんだけ表が誰かに行ったら私ちょっとね
調べてみましたこのドンブラコね google
先生に聞いてみたんですよ一体英語でどんな風に訳されるんやと
そうすると皆さん
大土呂期の結果になりましたよ
刮目してくださいこうなりました
ワンダーくーん
ドンブラーコーン
そのまんまやないかと思うんですけどもねっ
ですからねを物音でまぁ擬音語擬態語これに実は5500種類あるといわれています
すごい数ですよね日本語の中でだからね私はこのね日本語ってほんと素晴らしいなと
思うんです
でもね時々こういうこと言われたことないですか日本人でね自己主張下手くそやなとか
日本人ってなかなか事故死兆星変なあって
そんな風に聞いたことが一度はあると思います
でもねぇ私から言わせたらねこれ事故死兆星編にはないもっと言うと事故死とできいい
んじゃないんですよええ
相手の音想像力慮るがゆえにね相手の中にあるものを大切にしようとそういった姿勢が
そういうふうな空白を生み
そしてせっ
はいにも類を見ないほどの膨大な擬音語擬態語大ノマ米を作り出してそれらを利用して
我々の先祖というのはいつの時代でも豊かな人間観って豊かな地域社会
あるいはぷにゃ豊かな世界を作り上げてきたやないかなぁってそんなふうに思い始めた
んです
だからね相手の心をつかむためにはあるいは機器でのハートを射止めるためには相手の
中に豊かなものを植え付けてあげる
その植え付ける土壌が実は20%の空白選んやないかなってそんなふうに思います
でもなぁ
俺車ベリー下手だしなそんな風に思われた方も中にはいるかもしれません
あるいはね今まで何かを伝えようとして上手くいかなかったそれがトラウマになって
を尻込みしてしまう人とか後ずさりしてしまう人とかね諦めてきた人とか中には
いらっしゃるかもしれないんですよ
でも
大丈夫ですどういったことか今から2つ俳句を見ていただきますこんな俳句ですね
初雪や閣僚旺盛の5万の品あるいは
ツクツクボウシツクツクボウシばかりなりとどちらかというとこれもっちゃりした空な
んですけども入ったこれ誰が選んだんでしょ
正岡子規が選んだんですよ正岡子規で18歳から34歳の猫17年間の間に何と短歌と
はいと合わせて4万94万歩読んでるんですね
濃厚してるだけで4万ですからということは書いてこの灯りで敗としててしまったです
とか頭に浮かんだけどどんなあ構えてシュッとしててしまったやつとか
そんな
あはしたら4万9どころか何十万円多分考えたじゃないかなそんな失敗いっぱいしてき
たなかであのパピクウェバーという超人的な俳句が生まれてきたんじゃないかなって
失敗したからそんなが出てきたじゃないかなって思うなったんですねなんて何でそんな
事言えるか
そうなんです私も実はいっぱい失敗してるんですよ恥をさらす
そうですけどねあっちこっち失敗してます失敗やばですわ
でもその失敗することで実は
音色もパチってのは存在するんですねどういったことか
一番最初に観ていただいた澪ちゃんの0
ね皆さんこれいったいみおちゃんどんな人なんかラーって田畑真ん中で描いたと思うん
です
ね
さあ来い美容ちゃんに会いに行きましたネス子達に会いに行きました
興味をちゃんいるのごめんなさい今日休みなんです
今日はミお茶いるのあー今日も休みなんです
そう澪じゃあいつ行ってもこれねおやすみ
なんでそうその通り実在しない人物架空の人物なんですよ
えーなんやーこれ架空の人物実は異性のが残念やなぁと思ったかもしれませんがでも私
がこの話を一番最初にしたときにみなさんの頭の中には1人
一人の澪ちゃん像が浮かび上がってその身をたがいたからこそこのポテトサラダがより
魅力的なより豊らより豊穣な品物に変わったんじゃないですか
からね空白から豊かさって生まれるんですねその余白が北条さんを生み出すんですです
からこれから先の人生
少し少しだけでいいんで相手にとっての20%聞き手にとっても20%
俺を意識して伝えてみませんか
間違えなく挑む価値は
部分にあります
ありがとうございました
[拍手]